The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to offer
high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare at
OCW.mit.edu.
Thank you.
Let's continue with vectors and
operations of them.
Remember we saw the topic
yesterday was dot product.
And remember the definition of
dot product,
well, the dot product of two
vectors is obtained by
multiplying the first component
with the first component,
the second with the second and
so on and summing these and you
get the scalar.
And the geometric
interpretation of that is that
you can also take the length of
A,
take the length of B multiply
them and multiply that by the
cosine of the angle between the
two vectors.
We have seen several
applications of that.
One application is to find
lengths and angles.
For example,
you can use this relation to
give you the cosine of the angle
between two vectors is the dot
product divided by the product
of the lengths.
Another application that we
have is to detect whether two
vectors are perpendicular.
To decide if two vectors are
perpendicular to each other,
all we have to do is compute
our dot product and see if we
get zero.
And one further application
that we did not have time to
discuss yesterday that I will
mention very quickly is to find
components of,
let's say, a vector A along a
direction u.
So some unit vector.
Let me explain.
Let's say that I have some
direction.
For example,
the horizontal axis on this
blackboard.
But it could be any direction
in space.
And, to describe this
direction, maybe I have a unit
vector along this axis.
Let's say that I have any of a
vector A and I want to find out
what is the component of A along
u.
That means what is the length
of this projection of A to the
given direction?
This thing here is the
component of A along u.
Well, how do we find that?
Well, we know that here we have
a right angle.
So this component is just
length A times cosine of the
angle between A and u.
But now that means I should be
able to compute it very easily
because that's the same as
length A times length u times
cosine theta because u is a unit
vector.
It is a unit vector.
That means this is equal to one.
And so that's the same as the
dot product between A and u.
That is very easy.
And, of course,
the most of just cases of that
is say, for example,
we want just to find the
component along i hat,
the unit vector along the x
axis.
Then you do the dot product
with i hat, which is 100.
What you get is the first
component.
And that is,
indeed, the x component of a
vector.
Similarly, say you want the z
component you do the dot product
with k that gives you the last
component of your vector.
But the same works with a unit
vector in any direction.
So what is an application of
that?
Well, for example,
in physics maybe you have seen
situations where you have a
pendulum that swings.
You have maybe some mass at the
end of the string and that mass
swings back and forth on a
circle.
And to analyze this
mechanically you want to use,
of course,
Newton's Laws of Mechanics and
you want to use forces and so
on,
but I claim that components of
vectors are useful here to
understand what happens
geometrically.
What are the forces exerted on
this pendulum?
Well, there is its weight,
which usually points downwards,
and there is the tension of the
string.
And these two forces together
are what explains how this
pendulum is going to move back
and forth.
Now, you could try to
understand the equations of
motion using x,
y coordinates or x,
z or whatever you want to call
them, let's say x,
y.
But really what causes the
pendulum to swing back and forth
and also to somehow stay a
constant distance are phenomenal
relative to this circular
trajectory.
For example,
maybe instead of taking
components along the x and y
axis, we want to look at two
other unit vectors.
We can look at a vector,
let's call it T,
that is tangent to the
trajectory.
Sorry. Can you read that?
It's not very readable.
T is tangent to the trajectory.
And, on the other hand,
we can introduce another
vector.
Let's call that N.
And that one is normal,
perpendicular to the
trajectory.
And so now if you think about
it you can look at the
components of the weight along
the tangent direction and along
the normal direction.
And so the component of F along
the tangent direction is what
causes acceleration in the
direction along the trajectory.
It is what causes the pendulum
to swing back and forth.
And the component along N,
on the other hand.
That is the part of the weight
that tends to pull our mass away
from this point.
It is what is going to be
responsible for the tension of
the string.
It is why the string is taut
and not actually slack and with
things moving all over the
place.
That one is responsible for the
tension of a string.
And now, of course,
if you want to compute things,
well, maybe you will call this
angle theta and then you will
express things explicitly using
sines and cosines and you will
solve for the equations of
motion.
That would be a very
interesting physics problem.
But, to save time,
we are not going to do it.
I'm sure you've seen that in
8.01 or similar classes.
And so to find these components
we will just do dot products.
Any questions?
No.
OK.
Let's move onto our next topic.
Here we have found things about
lengths, angles and stuff like
that.
One important concept that we
have not understood yet in terms
of vectors is area.
Let's say that we want to find
the area of this pentagon.
Well, how do we compute that
using vectors?
Can we do it using vectors?
Yes we can.
And that is going to be the
goal.
The first thing we should do is
probably simplify the problem.
We don't actually need to
bother with pentagons.
All we need to know are
triangles because,
for example,
you can cut that in three
triangles and then sum the areas
of the triangles.
Perhaps easier,
what is the area of a triangle?
Let's start with a triangle in
the plane.
Well, then we need two vectors
to describe it,
say A and B here.
How do we find the area of a
triangle?
Well, we all know base times
height over two.
What is the base?
What is the height?
The area of this triangle is
going to be one-half of the
base, which is going to be the
length of A.
And the height,
well, if you call theta this
angle, then this is length B
sine theta.
Now, that looks a lot like the
formula we had there,
except for one little catch.
This is a sine instead of a
cosine.
How do we deal with that?
Well, what we could do is first
find the cosine of the angle.
We know how to find the cosine
of the angle using dot products.
Then solve for sine using sine
square plus cosine square equals
one.
And then plug that back into
here.
Well, that works but it is kind
of a very complicated way of
doing it.
So there is an easier way.
And that is going to be
determinants,
but let me explain how we get
to that maybe still doing
elementary geometry and dot
products first.
Let's see.
What we can do is instead of
finding the sine of theta,
well,
we're not good at finding sines
of angles but we are very good
now at finding cosines of
angles.
Maybe we can find another angle
whose cosine is the same as the
sine of theta.
Well, you have already heard
about complimentary angles and
how I take my vector A,
my vector B here and I have an
angle theta.
Well, let's say that I rotate
my vector A by 90 degrees to get
a new vector A prime.
A prime is just A rotated by 90
degrees.
Then the angle between these
two guys, let's say theta prime,
well, theta prime is 90 degrees
or pi over two gradients minus
theta.
So, in particular,
cosine of theta prime is equal
to sine of theta.
In particular,
that means that length A,
length B, sine theta,
which is what we would need to
know in order to find the area
of this triangle is equal to,
well, A and A prime have the
same length so let me replace
that by length of A prime.
I am not changing anything,
length B, cosine theta prime.
And now we have something that
is much easier for us.
Because that is just A prime
dot B.
That looks like a very good
plan.
There is only one small thing
which is we don't know yet how
to find this A prime.
Well, I think it is not very
hard.
Let's see.
Actually, why don't you guys do
the hard work?
Let's say that I have a plane
vector A with two components a1,
a2.
And I want to rotate it
counterclockwise by 90 degrees.
It looks like maybe we should
change some signs somewhere.
Maybe we should do something
with the components.
Can you come up with an idea of
what it might be?
I see a lot of people answering
three.
I see some other answers,
but the majority vote seems to
be number three.
Minus a2 and a1.
I think I agree, so let's see.
Let's say that we have this
vector A with components a1.
So a1 is here.
And a2. So a2 is here.
Let's rotate this box by 90
degrees counterclockwise.
This box ends up there.
It's the same box just flipped
on its side.
This thing here becomes a1 and
this thing here becomes a2.
And that means our new vector A
prime is going to be -- Well,
the first component looks like
an a2 but it is pointing to the
left when a2 is positive.
So, actually, it is minus a2.
And the y component is going to
be the same as this guy,
so it's going to be a1.
If you wanted instead to rotate
clockwise then you would do the
opposite.
You would do a2 minus a1.
Is that reasonably clear for
everyone?
OK.
Let's continue the calculation
there.
A prime, we have decided,
is minus a2,
a1 dot product with let's call
b1 and b2, the components of B.
Then that will be minus a2,
b1 plus a1, b2 plus a1,
b2.
Let me write that the other way
around, a1, b2 minus a2,
b1.
And that is a quantity that you
may already know under the name
of determinant of vectors A and
B, which we write symbolically
using this notation.
We put A and B next to each
other inside a two-by-two table
and we put these verticals bars.
And that means the determinant
of these numbers,
this guy times this guy minus
this guy times this guy.
That is called the determinant.
And geometrically what it
measures is the area,
well, not of a triangle because
we did not divide by two,
but of a parallelogram formed
by A and B.
It measures the area of the
parallelogram with sides A and
B.
And, of course,
if you want the triangle then
you will just divide by two.
The triangle is half the
parallelogram.
There is one small catch.
The area usually is something
that is going to be positive.
This guy here has no reason to
be positive or negative because,
in fact, well,
if you compute things you will
see that where it is supposed to
go negative it depends on
whether A and B are clockwise or
counterclockwise from each
other.
I mean the issue that we have
-- Well,
when we say the area is
one-half length A,
length B,
sine theta that was assuming
that theta is positive,
that its sine is positive.
Otherwise, if theta is negative
maybe we need to take the
absolute value of this.
Just to be more truthful,
I will say the determinant is
either plus or minus the area.
Any questions about this?
Yes.
Sorry.
That is not a dot product.
That is the usual
multiplication.
That is length A times length B
times sine theta.
What does that equal?
And so that is equal to the
area of a parallelogram.
Sorry.
Let me explain that again.
If I have two vectors A and B,
I can form a parallelogram with
them or I can form a triangle.
And so the area of a
parallelogram is equal to length
A, length B, sine theta,
is equal to the determinant of
A and B.
While the area of a triangle is
one-half of that.
And, again, to be truthful,
I should say these things can
be positive or negative.
Depending on whether you count
the angle positively or
negatively, you will get either
the area or minus the area.
The area is actually the
absolute value of these
quantities.
Is that clear?
OK.
Yes.
If you want to compute the
area, you will just take the
absolute value of the
determinant.
I should say the area of a
parallelogram so that it is
completely clear.
Sorry. Do you have a question?
Explain again,
sorry, was the question how a
determinant equals the area of a
parallelogram?
OK.
The area of a parallelogram is
going to be the base times the
height.
Let's take this guy to be the
base.
The length of a base will be
length of A and the height will
be obtained by taking B but only
looking at the vertical part.
That will be length of B times
the sine of theta.
That is how I got the area of a
parallelogram as length A,
length B, sine theta.
And then I did this
manipulation and this trick of
rotating to find a nice formula.
Yes.
You are asking ahead of what I
am going to do in a few minutes.
You are asking about magnitude
of A cross B.
We are going to learn about
cross products in a few minutes.
And the answer is yes,
but cross product is for
vectors in space.
Here I was simplifying things
by doing things just in the
plane.
Just bear with me for five more
minutes and we will do things in
space.
Yes. That is correct.
The way you compute this in
practice is you just do this.
That is how you compute the
determinant.
Yes.
What about three dimensions?
Three dimensions we are going
to do now.
More questions?
Should we move on?
OK. Let's move to space.
There are two things we can do
in space.
And you can look for the volume
of solids or you can look for
the area of surfaces.
Let me start with the easier of
the two.
Let me start with volumes of
solids.
And we will go back to area,
I promise.
I claim that there is also a
notion of determinants in space.
And that is going to tell us
how to find volumes.
Let's say that we have three
vectors A, B and C.
And then the definition of
their determinants going to be,
the notation for that in terms
of the components is the same as
over there.
We put the components of A,
the components of B and the
components of C inside verticals
bars.
And, of course,
I have to give meaning to this.
This will be a number.
And what is that number?
Well, the definition I will
take is that this is a1 times
the determinant of what I get by
looking in this lower right
corner.
The two-by-two determinant b2,
b3, c2, c3.
Then I will subtract a2 times
the determinant of b1,
b3, c1, c3.
And then I will add a3 times
the determinant b1,
b2, c1, c2.
And each of these guys means,
again, you take b2 times c3
minus c2 times b3 and this times
that minus this time that and so
on.
In fact, there is a total of
six terms in here.
And maybe some of you have
already seen a different formula
for three-by-three determinants
where you directly have the six
terms.
It is the same definition.
How to remember the structure
of this formula?
Well, this is called an
expansion according to the first
row.
So we are going to take the
entries in the first row,
a1, a2, a3 And for each of them
we get the term.
Namely we multiply it by a
two-by-two determinant that we
get by deleting the first row
and the column where we are.
Here the coefficient next to
a1, when we delete this column
and this row,
we are left with b2,
b3, c2, c3.
The next one we take a2,
we delete the row that is in it
and the column that it is in.
And we are left with b1,
b3, c1, c3.
And, similarly,
with a3, we take what remains,
which is b1,
b2, c1, c2.
Finally, last but not least,
there is a minus sign here for
the second guy.
It looks like a weird formula.
I mean it is a little bit weird.
But it is a formula that you
should learn because it is
really, really useful for a lot
of things.
I should say if this looks very
artificial to you and you would
like to know more there is more
in the notes,
so read the notes.
They will tell you a bit more
about what this means,
where it comes from and so on.
If you want to know a lot more
then some day you should take
18.06,
Linear Algebra where you will
learn a lot more about
determinants in N dimensional
space with N vectors.
And there is a generalization
of this in arbitrary dimensions.
In this class,
we will only deal with two or
three dimensions.
Yes.
Why is the negative there?
Well, that is a very good
question.
It has to be there so that this
will actually equal,
well, what I am going to say
right now is that this will give
us the volume of [a box?]
with sides A,
B, C.
And the formula just doesn't
work if you don't put the
negative.
There is a more fundamental
reason which has to do with
orientation of space and the
fact that if you switch two
coordinates in space then
basically you change what is
called the handedness of the
coordinates.
If you look at your right hand
and your left hand,
they are not actually the same.
They are mirror images.
And, if you squared two
coordinate axes,
that is what you get.
That is the fundamental reason
for the minus.
Again, we don't need to think
too much about that.
All we need in this class is
the formula.
Why do we care about this
formula?
It is because of the theorem
that says that geometrically the
determinant of the three vectors
A, B, C is, again,
plus or minus.
This determinant could be
positive or negative.
See those minuses and all sorts
of stuff.
Plus or minus the volume of the
parallelepiped.
That is just a fancy name for a
box with parallelogram sides,
in case you wonder,
with sides A,
B and C.
You take the three vectors A,
B and C and you form a box
whose sides are all
parallelograms.
And when its volume is going to
be the determinant.
Other questions?
I'm sorry.
I cannot quite hear you.
Yes.
We are going to see how to do
it geometrically without a
determinant,
but then you will see that you
actually need a determinant to
compute it no matter what.
We are going to go back to this
and see another formula for
volume, but you will see that
really I am cheating.
I mean somehow computationally
the only way to compute it is
really to use a determinant.
That is correct.
In general, I mean,
actually, I could say if you
look at the two-by-two
determinant, see,
you can also explain it in
terms of this extension.
If you take a1 and multiply by
this one-by-one determinant b2,
then you take a2 and you
multiply it by this one-by-one
determinant b1 but you put a
minus sign.
And in general,
indeed, when you expand,
you would stop putting plus,
minus, plus,
minus alternating.
More about that in 18.06.
Yes.
There is a way to do it based
on other rows as well,
but then you have to be very
careful with the sign vectors.
I will refer you to the notes
for that.
I mean you could also do it
with a column,
by the way.
I mean be careful about the
sign rules.
Given how little we will use
determinants in this class,
I mean we will use them in a
way that is fundamental,
but we won't compute much.
Let's say this is going to be
enough for us for now.
After determinants now I can
tell you about cross product.
And cross product is going to
be the answer to your question
about area.
OK.
Let me move onto cross product.
Cross product is something that
you can apply to two vectors in
space.
And by that I mean really in
three-dimensional space.
This is something that is
specific to three dimensions.
The definition A cross B -- It
is important to really do your
multiplication symbol well so
that you don't mistake it with a
dot product.
Well, that is going to be a
vector.
That is another reason not to
confuse it with dot product.
Dot product gives you a number.
Cross product gives you a
vector.
They are really completely
different operations.
They are both called product
because someone could not come
up with a better name,
but they are completely
different operations.
What do we do to do the cross
product of A and B?
Well, we do something very
strange.
Just as I have told you that a
determinant is something where
we put numbers and we get a
number, I am going to violate my
own rule.
I am going to put together a
determinant in which -- Well,
the last two rows are the
components of the vectors A and
B but the first row strangely
consists for unit vectors i,
j, k.
What does that mean?
Well, that is not a determinant
in the usual sense.
If you try to put that into
your calculator,
it will tell you there is an
error.
I don't know how to put vectors
in there.
I want numbers.
What is means is it is symbolic
notation that helps you remember
what the formula is.
The actual formula is,
well, you use this definition.
And, if you use that
definition, you see that it is i
hat times some number.
Let me write it as determinant
of a2, a3, b2,
b3 times i hat minus
determinant a1,
a3, b1, b3, j hat plus a1,
a2, b1, b2, k hat.
And so that is the actual
definition in a way that makes
complete sense,
but to remember this formula
without too much trouble it is
much easier to think about it in
these terms here.
That is the definition and it
gives you a vector.
Now, as usual with definitions,
the question is what is it good
for?
What is the geometric meaning
of this very strange operation?
Why do we bother to do that?
Here is what it does
geometrically.
Remember a vector has two
different things.
It has a length and it has a
direction.
Let's start with the length.
A length of a cross product is
the area of the parallelogram in
space formed by the vectors A
and B.
Now, if you have a
parallelogram in space,
you can find its area just by
doing this calculation when you
know the coordinates of the
points.
You do this calculation and
then you take the length.
You take this squared plus that
squared plus that squared,
square root.
It looks like a very
complicated formula but it works
and, actually,
it is the simplest way to do
it.
This time we don't actually
need to put plus or minus
because the length of a vector
is always positive.
We don't have to worry about
that.
And what is even more magical
is that not only is the length
remarkable but the direction is
also remarkable.
The direction of A cross B is
perpendicular to the plane of a
parallelogram.
Our two vectors A and B
together in a plane.
What I am telling you is that
for vector A cross B will point,
will stick straight out of that
plane perpendicularly to it.
In fact, I would have to be
more precise.
There are two ways that you can
be perpendicular to this plane.
You can be perpendicular
pointing up or pointing down.
How do I decide which?
Well, there is something called
the right-hand rule.
What does the right-hand rule
say?
Well, there are various
versions for right-hand rule
depending on which country you
learn about it.
In France, given the culture,
you even learn about it in
terms of a cork screw and a wine
bottle.
I will just use the usual
version here.
You take your right hand.
If you are left-handed,
remember to take your right
hand and not the left one.
The other right, OK?
Then place your hand to point
in the direction of A.
Let's say my right hand is
going in that direction.
Now, curl your fingers so that
they point towards B.
Here that would be kind of into
the blackboard.
Don't snap any bones.
If it doesn't quite work then
rotate your arms so that you can
actually physically do it.
Then get your thumb to stick
straight out.
Well, here my thumb is going to
go up.
And that tells me that A cross
B will go up.
Let me write that down while
you experiment with it.
Again, try not to enjoy
yourselves.
First, your right hand points
parallel to vector A.
Then your fingers point in the
direction of B.
Then your thumb,
when you stick it out,
is going to point in the
direction of A cross B.
Let's do a quick example.
Where is my quick example? Here.
Let's take i cross j.
I see most of you going in the
right direction.
If you have it pointing in the
wrong direction,
it might mean that you are
using your left hand,
for example.
Example, I claim that i cross j
equals k.
Let's see. I points towards us.
J point to our right.
I guess this is your right.
I think.
And then your thumb is going to
point up.
That tells us it is roughly
pointing up.
And, of course,
the length should be one
because if you take the unit
square in the x,
y plane, its area is one.
And the direction should be
vertical.
Because it should be
perpendicular to the x,
y plane.
It looks like i cross j will be
k.
Well, let's check with the
definition i,
j, k.
What is i? I is one, zero, zero.
J is zero, one, zero.
The coefficient of i will be
zero times zero minus zero times
one.
That is zero.
The coefficient of j will be
one time zero minus zero times
zero, that is a zero,
minus zero j.
It doesn't matter.
And the coefficient of k will
be one times one,
that is one,
minus zero times zero,
so one k.
So we do get i cross j equals k
both ways.
In this case,
it is easier to do it
geometrically.
If I give you no complicated
vectors, probably you will
actually want to do the
calculation.
Any questions? Yes.
The coefficient of k,
remember I delete the first row
and the last column so I get
this two-by-two determinant.
And that two-by-two determinant
is one times one minus zero
times zero so that gives me a
one.
That is what you do with
two-by-two determinants.
Similarly for [UNINTELLIGIBLE],
but [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
turn out to be zero.
More questions?
Yes.
Let me repeat how I got the one
in front of k.
Remember the definition of a
determinant I expand according
to the entries in the first row.
When I get to k what I do is
delete the first row and I
delete the last column,
the column that contains k.
I delete these guys and these
guys and I am left with this
two-by-two determinant.
Now, a two-by-two determinant,
you multiply according to this
downward diagonal and then minus
this times that.
One times one,
let me see here,
I got one k because that is one
times one minus zero times zero
equals one.
Sorry.
That is really hard to read.
Maybe it will be easier that
way.
Yes.
Let's try.
If I do the same for i,
I think I will also get zero.
Let's do the same for i.
I take i, I delete the first
row, I delete the first column,
I get this two-by-two
determinant here and I get zero
times zero,
that is zero,
minus zero times one.
That is the other trick
question.
Zero times one is zero as well.
So that zero minus zero is
zero.
I hope on Monday you should get
more practice in recitation
about how to compute
determinants.
Hopefully, it will become very
easy for you all to compute this
next.
I know the first time it is
kind of a shock because there
are a lot of numbers and a lot
of things to do.
Let me return to the question
that you asked a bit earlier
about how do you find actually
volume if I don't want to know
about determinants?
Well, let's have another look
at the volume.
Let's say that I have three
vectors.
Let me put them this way,
A, B and C.
And let's try to see how else I
could think about the volume of
this box.
Probably you know that the
volume of a parallelepiped is
the area of a base times the
height.
Sorry.
The volume is the area of a
base times the height.
How do we do that in practice?
Well, what is the area of a
base?
The base is a parallelogram in
space with sides B and C.
How do we find the area of the
parallelogram in space?
Well, we just discovered that.
We can do it by taking that
cross product.
The area of a base,
well, we take the cross product
of B and C.
That is not quite it because
this is a vector.
We would like a number while we
take its length.
That is pretty good.
What about the height?
Well, the height is going to be
the component of A in the
direction that is perpendicular
to the base.
Let's take a direction that is
perpendicular to the base.
Let's call that N,
a unit vector in that
direction.
Then we can get the height by
taking A dot n.
That is what we saw at the
beginning of class that A dot n
will tell me how much A goes in
the direction of n.
Are you still with me?
OK.
Let's keep going.
Let's think about this vector
n.
How do I get it?
Well, I can get it by actually
using cross product as well.
Because I said the direction
perpendicular to two vectors I
can get by taking that cross
product and looking at that
direction.
This is still B cross C length.
And this one is,
so I claim, n can be obtained
by taking D cross C.
Well, that comes in the right
direction but it is not a unit
vector.
How do I get a unit vector?
I divide by the length.
Thanks.
I take B cross C and I divide
by length B cross C.
Well, now I can probably
simplify between these two guys.
And so what I will get -- What
I get out of this is that my
volume equals A dot product with
vector B cross C.
But, of course,
I have to be careful in which
order I do it.
If I do it the other way
around, A dot B,
I get a number.
I cannot cross that.
I really have to do the cross
product first.
I get the new vector.
Then my dot product.
The fact is that the
determinant of A,
B, C is equal to this so-called
triple product.
Well, that looks good
geometrically.
Let's try to check whether it
makes sense with the formulas,
just one small thing.
We saw the determinant is a1
times determinant b2,
b3, c2, c3 minus a2 times
something plus a3 times
something.
I will let you fill in the
numbers.
That is this guy.
What about this guy?
Well, dot product,
we take the first component of
A, that is a1,
we multiply by the first
component of B cross C.
What is the first component of
B cross C?
Well, it is this determinant
b2, b3, c2, c3.
If you put B and C instead of A
and B into there you will get
the i component is this guy plus
a2 times the second component
which is minus some determinant
plus a3 times the third
component which is,
again, a determinant.
And you can check.
You get exactly the same
expression, so everything is
fine.
There is no contradiction in
math just yet.
On Tuesday we will continue
with this and we will start
going into matrices,
equations of planes and so on.
Meanwhile, have a good weekend
and please start working on your
Problem Sets so that you can ask
lots of questions to your TAs on
Monday.